i mean it's an amazing scheme it gives
us a great opportunity
this managing director of a production
company talking to the work and pension
secretary
grateful for new government funding in
tough times
molinaire in central london has just
landed 37 placements
on the new two billion pound kickstarter
scheme to give young people on benefits
the chance of a job the kickstart jobs
and new jobs people will get national
insurance paid
the pensions paid it's not just a trial
but it's really about making sure they
have a proper active job
but also the extra funding of 1500
pounds per person
will give them that wrap around support
so they can develop some of the softer
skills and basically
get ready for the next part of their
career
launched this month 65 000 applications
for placements are already
in but as these young people pursue
their careers
the country's bracing for unemployment
levels
not seen for decades where do you think
it's going uh in the next few months are
we going to hit four million
three what are you planning for well we
do use
our own scenarios working across
government of course the obr has set out
a forecast the obr was saying four
million unemployed by the middle of next
year that's 13.2 percent
well they've also keep revising
different elements and that's why we
need to adapt
um our plans and our approaches and
trying to
try and keep as many people are you
planning for that amount
um i think we're we're in a number
similar
in terms of being ready to help people
you are planning for the worst case
scenario four million unemployed
i generally hope that we don't reach
obviously that figure
but it's important that we are ready to
help people but the opposition aren't
convinced the government's doing enough
ministers are just far too relaxed about
the scale of potential job losses
if you look at the sectors that will be
hardest hit so particularly
parts of the country have a lot of
retail jobs that have a lot of
manufacturing jobs
you know those will be the north and the
midlands that will be hit
disproportionately it will be like the
1980s and early 90s
all over again young people have been
hard hit by this pandemic nearly a
million
now on benefits miss coffee hopes
kickstart will give tens of thousands of
them
a route into employment at a time when
jobs are increasingly scarce
beth rigby sky news central london